all right the national death toll from
coronavirus has now increased to 9 all
in Washington State most of those cases
are linked to a nursing home outside
Seattle nationwide at least a hundred 26
people have fallen ill in 16 states
Jonathan Vigliotti reports from Seattle
where one case in particular is causing
concern one of the newest coronavirus
cases in Washington is an Amazon
employee at this office building in
Seattle that worker is now quarantined
and people who'd been in close contact
have been notified this Washington State
nursing home associated with five
confirmed deaths he's now tied to a case
across the country a North Carolina
resident who visited the facility and
then flew back east officials say that
patient is now in isolation we are doing
and starting that work now to trace
folks immediate contacts that they would
have had and that includes going back to
making sure folks on that flight are
made aware in New York health officials
confirmed a second case a fifty year old
man who worked at a Manhattan law firm
he is in serious condition his family is
quarantined and the schools his children
attended are being cleaned back in
Washington State King County officials
have set up the first of up to 18
modular units that will be used to house
coronavirus patients in isolation each
unit has four rooms with eight beds
total public health will determine how
many people per room they might decide
there should only be one person per room
workers at the life care center nursing
home tell us the facility is severely
short-staffed because employees with
symptoms are staying home another worker
says the nursing home is pulling
employees from other affiliated
locations experts say an overburdened
workforce could be an ongoing concern we
could see a surge in our health care
system overwhelming our hospitals and
our primary care centers we don't have
the resources to combat this outbreak by
any means and a lack of resources have
led to some pretty desperate measures
like what's unfolding here in Seattle
this is the location for those isolation
units where hundreds of patients could
spend up to two weeks in quarantine and
recover and me
while lawmakers in Washington DC working
to approve an emergency budget of over 8
billion dollars to help fight this virus
Gail Jonathan thank you very much